we're taking calls at six one seven
eight three zero
4750 let's go to our next caller from
the six seven eight area code caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from
you're on the air we can barely hear you
it sounds like you're in a wind tunnel
but we you are on the air if we can get
the background noise down a little bit
we might be able to hear you it's not
better now we can barely hear you hello
now that's much better
Oh who's this hello can you hear me oh
yes I hear you good I just got a one
little small of course I'm a very
religious man enough I'm married and if
you notice I'm not Donald Trump you
don't you don't wear our weight in vain
kind of secure to me does that bother
you in some way I mean you know you
would think about if somebody that's a
little leader of the free world or to me
it's kinda important in what way like in
other words what does it mean to you
that Donald Trump doesn't wear a wedding
band I mean you the same with his wife
if you live the person I think Lisa he
believes in God like he does I would
think he was sort of world this is
something you wanted to you know please
most guys don't worry I mean you know
they try to hide something well I don't
think Trump's really doing a good job of
hiding it he's on video saying he tries
to grab women by the [ __ ] right so I
don't think you have to look too far to
figure out what what he might be hiding
hey but I'm curious about that what is
there something about I didn't realize
that in the religious community wearing
a wedding band was a big thing is that
the case at least in your in your
congregation I'm a man my wife I don't
have my own name she think I'm trying to
hide some of you the most meaning when
they cry in public they take they take
it off you know they don't want people
know that they marry yeah I mean Trump
isn't really much of a traditional guy
he's been divorced twice now
and also Melania doesn't even plan on
living in the White House they're not
even gonna live together so he may
pretend to be a traditional Christian
type but he's really not
hey let me ask you this though while I
have you as a deeply really are you are
you a religious trump supporter or your
religious but not a trump supporter not
you know I'm not a supporter but you
know I believe in God and doing the
right thing you know saying that's
something to mean that's sacred you know
you if she's gonna be married you got to
me it's important I mean it is a good
example it's like the picture of your
church Dizzy's marry you don't want
obeying how would you looking do you
believe that Donald Trump is a religious
man as he's claimed you know what that's
a good at I don't think so I meant but
he talked about God and Goddess and God
that but I don't think so so in other
words what you're saying is that as
someone who I presume you've been
religious have you been religious most
of your life yes right so if someone
who's been religious your whole life
when you see Trump talk about religion
and talk about God like he did in the
speech earlier this week
it doesn't seem authentic to you you're
saying I mean I mean I mean a lot of
these thing but you know I should speak
louder than words I mean to me just by
not wearing that being alone tells me
that the only bleeding no matter to me
to me that sacred yeah
well listen interesting interesting
perspective as a non-religious person I
think everything that he says about
religion is total BS so that that's my
perspective as a non-religious person I
really appreciate the call very very
interesting topic and I appreciate you
raising it I don't know noticed it maybe
with just me but also you know and
that's kind of like maybe we just mean
notice that thank you oh no you're not
the only person who's noticed that
there's something weird going on with
Trump's marriage and his religious
statements no maybe maybe his hands are
too small so they won't support a ring
on the phone they don't make ring small
enough to stay on